montag 9 märz 9 uhr in der maria
theresien kaserne in wien
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
und innenminister karl hammer treten
gemeinsam vor die versammelte presse der
bundeskanzler hat mich und die
verteidigungsministerin damit beauftragt
sorge dafür zu tragen dass sich bilder
wie 2015 nicht mehr wiederholen sowohl
die polizei als auch das bundesheer
haben aus den erfahrungen von 2015
gelernt tatsächlich dafür zu sorgen dass
die bevölkerung auch von uns erwartet
nämlich sicherheit zu schaffen
zum abschluss bedankten sich
verteidigungsminister in tanna und
innenminister nie hammer bei den
angetretenen